cleaning your fruits and vegetables with
bleach is effective
that is completely false all schools
should reopen
because kids can't get covered 19.
we used to think that but now we know
it's not true
hi i'm steve morris professor of
epidemiology
my name is dr sarah madon and i'm an
infectious disease epidemiologist here
in new york city
in the past we have debunked a number of
myths
but new myths keep coming up and the
same old ones keep coming back
so let's get to work debunking more
myths today
wearing a mask doesn't do anything and
there are people who believe
that and one reason is that until
recently
we weren't really recommending masks
because we didn't know that they
actually
do a lot of good there's a recent study
from
hong kong that was published in nature
that proves that even
surgical mass can prevent infected
people
from passing on the infection to others
we have seen that in states that didn't
have a mass
mandate once they had that mass mandate
over a period of time you did see the
number of cases go down it's important
to continue to
wash your hands and keep your distance
while also wearing a mask
wearing a mask is dangerous because
you'll get carbon dioxide
poisoning but it takes a lot of carbon
dioxide to do it
and all of that actually goes through
the mask
quite readily so it doesn't build up in
the mask
and we know that even when people are
wearing masks
their oxygen levels in the blood are
perfectly normal
if they're not sick so part of it is
really
getting used to it the way we get used
to wearing a necktie for example
looking at those healthcare workers that
do wear for an extended period of time
that's a great model to show you that
does not cause carbon dioxide
poisoning or toxicity all schools should
reopen
because kids can't get covered 19.
once the schools reopen we're going to
see a situation where there are a lot of
kids together
and the possibility of transmission
becomes much greater and on top of that
it's not also just the kids it's also
the teachers and the adults that are in
these schools that
are also at risk and so we want to
protect everybody there are countries in
asia that have reopened schools
successfully and have been able to
remain open they started off with
having low number of cases and they also
had contingency plans in place where you
have smaller classroom sizes
children sitting further apart wearing
masks you also have countries that have
shown that they opened
uh schools too early and then they had
to close down multiple times and so we
want to make sure we're in a position
that we have the upper hand when it
comes to this virus asymptomatic people
aren't contagious
asymptomatic people people who feel and
look perfectly well
are contagious to others and we worry
about them
because they may not know what they're
spreading in fact
during the early days that is when you
are most infectious
the reality is we have to assume that
anyone who
could have it indeed could have it
and they could pass it on to others this
is why we're making recommendations
that everybody should wear a mask even
if they're feeling well
because we don't know and they
themselves may not
know that they could be infected and
able to infect others
young healthy people won't die from
covenant 19.
we have seen cases where you have
individuals
that have no medical condition still
unfortunately die from coving 19.
it may be a very small proportion but
when you have a very large number of
infected people
those numbers add up very quickly we are
seeing based on certain data that is
coming out
is that even with young people if they
don't have a severe case of kevin 19
they are at increased risk for example
of strokes and other types of ailments
looking at the death rate in the young
is a false sense of security
you cannot get cause of 19 twice
we still don't know what long-term
immunity looks like and so
in the immediate future can you get
reinfected with covid19 in a short
period of time the likelihood is no
uh individuals that have been tested
positive again for cloven 19
likely just have residual virus in their
body or in their bodily fluids
but in terms of long term if you can you
get kobit 19 a year after or two years
after
you know that is something that we still
don't know yet and it's one of those
things that time will tell
if you get it again will it be less bad
will it be worse will it be the same we
don't know
you won't get the virus if you hold your
breath when someone sneezes or
coughs but what we know about these
virus particles is that they can still
land on your mucous membrane
even if you're not breathing so for
example if you're touching a high touch
surface and then you're touching your
mucous membrane
and obviously you're able to transmit
the virus through that
you know indirect means if you will so
we have alternatives
we have masks we have good hand hygiene
and social distancing to make sure that
you won't be in the line
of fire when somebody coughs or sneezes
that's a lot safer than holding your
breath consuming disinfectants will kill
the virus
bleach and other types of disinfectants
are not to be used for ingesting
or injecting or to put on on skin these
are corrosive chemicals
they can actually cause death and
disability use it on your floors
use it on your countertops that's where
it really does
the work and that's where it really
helps cleaning your fruits and
vegetables with bleach
is effective that is completely false if
you're going to be putting chemicals on
fruit and vegetables that you are then
going to ingest you're putting yourself
more in harm's way so washing your fruit
and vegetable is very similar to how you
were washing your fruit vegetable before
cover 19 existed washing it
under water and making sure that you're
cleaning any fruit and vegetable these
are just basic good practices
because it's not just cloven 19 that
obviously we want to make sure that
yeah we're preventing but it's also all
the other microbes that can cause
illnesses warm weather will stop the
coronavirus well here we are at the end
of july
and if anyone still believes that myth i
think we have plenty of proof
there's an epidemiological potential
significance to warmer weather because
people are going outside
but in terms of the weather itself and
the effect on the virus that you know
has not shown to have an impact
so until we find something like a
vaccine
that's effective or something else
that's going to stop it
this virus given the opportunity to
infect
will continue to infect 99 of cases
aren't dangerous yes it is
true that probably only about one
percent
of those people who get infected
and get sick are going to die
but many of the others will get very
sick
and some of the others will get so sick
that they may be affected for life our
indicator
should not be the death rate because you
can have individuals
that may have survived the infection of
kova 19 but then go on
to suffer a stroke because of the
long-term effects of clover 19.
so a lot of these cases really
are dangerous the united states has one
of the lowest mortality rates
taking the mortality at its face value
is a huge disservice because it's not
painting the full picture
in terms of the the whole effect that
coven 19
has on an individual unfortunately
when you think about the entire
population
our mortality rate is actually
unbelievably high
we don't really want to measure this by
the number of people
who get saved at the last minute what we
want to
aim for is really a low infection rate
because the infection is going to be
there mortality rate proves we're just
getting better
at treating the severe cases 5g
technology
is spreading covid19 kovid19 is spread
by respiratory droplets when somebody
coughs sneezes
uh or or talks 5d towers and technology
do not have an influence on your ability
to get infected with copay 19.
the reality is the two are totally
unrelated you can spread computer
viruses
through technology on the internet but
real viruses
requires human contact the media
is blowing the pandemic out of
proportion i really wish this were true
and i think it depends a lot on which
media you're listening to by talking
about conspiracy theories
and no big deal to say that it's all a
hoax
these things help the virus the virus
doesn't care
the reality is it's here it's real
it will infect given the opportunity
because it is science
and it is evidence and it is public
health that will save
lives it's not politicians uh it's not
you know conspiracy theories
it's not misinformation and as we
continue to learn together
the public health guidance will change
because we want to go with
what we know to be effective in terms of
keeping everybody
safe stay safe stay well
and stay tuned and stay informed and
that's very important